ia é um prazer imenso estar aqui como
gustavo falou bastante engajada nos
eventos do ted não ser convidada para
estar aqui é uma baita responsabilidade
mais uma honra
como disse na fala eu vim conversar com
vocês um pouco sobre escolhas escolheu
aprender mas eu vou trazer um pouco da
minha realidade tentar tornar um pouco
mais pessoal
então convido vocês uma reflexão comigo
hoje não sei se vocês lembram quando é
que o maior medo que vocês tinham quando
vocês eram crianças mas o meu maior medo
era perder meus pais ficava pensando
como é que seria a minha vida sem os
pais morreu assim que escolhas que eu
teria que fazer idade eu teria quando
isso acontecesse
será que eu teria que mudar de cidade
mudar de escola deixar amigos era algo
que me aterrorizavam a pensar que a
minha vida poderia mudar por uma uma
situação como essas
e diariamente isso acontece com muitas
pessoas ea forma como as pessoas lidam
com essa perda vai fazer um impacto
muito grande na vida delas
algumas pessoas infelizmente não
consegue lidar muito bem com isso e
acabam se apagando e no pulmão os
caminhos acabam sendo presos por exemplo
sabe-se que presos têm chance de duas a
três vezes mais de terem perdido os pais
ou seja o fato de eles terem perdido os
pais impactou de forma muito negativa
além de outras coisas que devem ter
acontecido nas suas vidas
outras pessoas reagem de outra forma e
fazem outras escolhas
assim puderam se endurecem nec uma casca
ela se torna mais resilientes e segue
por um outro caminho
a gente sabe também por exemplo que de
44 presidentes norte-americanos 20 deles
perderam quando crianças
um pai ou a mãe os dois ou seja esse
evento tão traumático que acontece na
vida de algumas crianças pode sim levar
para um caminho para o outro o que
difere essas pessoas foram as escolhas
pelas foram fazendo ao longo de suas
vidas
pequenas escolhas grandes escolhas e é
sobre isso que eu quero falar com vocês
hoje sobre escolhas
imagino que hoje
amanhã você já acordaram já fizeram
várias escolhas escolher o que vestir o
que tomar o café da manhã que caminho
para chegar aqui escolheram está
presente nesse evento e até mesmo onde
sentar aqui dentro
foi escolha simples a grande maioria das
escolhas que a gente faz no dia a dia
são escolha simples que não pára pra
pensar muito sobre ela são quase que
automáticas né o piloto automático
eu quando acorda de manhã já decidido
rapidamente que eu vou tomar meu café da
manhã não fico pensando refletindo sobre
todas as opções possíveis no mercado
claro que se eu viajo vou para o hotel e
tem aquele bife e norminha frente ali
sim eu paro e penso quais são todas as
minhas possibilidades de escolha mas no
dia a dia são escolha simples que eu não
tenho muito não perco o sono com isso né
mas foi uma escolha quando eu aponto
como uma coisa ao invés de outra eu fiz
uma escolha simples mas essas não são as
escolhas difíceis nessa não são as
escolhas que tira o nosso sono nos
deixam sem fome
a gente pede até o sono o cabelo né
essas não são essas escolhas que eu
quero falar com vocês hoje
por que escolher significa abrir mão de
outra coisa significa eleger algo
entendimento de outro é selecionar é
optar e preferir e escolherá diretamente
relacionado com responsabilidade
quando eu escolho eu preciso me tornar
responsável por essa minha escolha e é
aí que é difícil
é aí que fica complicado porque é muito
mais fácil quando outro escolhe pela
gente
aí a gente pode assumir uma uma posição
de vítima
afinal de contas eu não tive escolha mas
quando eu defino escolher eu preciso me
responsabilizar por isso
e é isso que a gente tenta fugir às
vezes é quando a gente tem uma escolha
difícil para fazer a gente procura
amigos familiares a gente ler um livro
que procura alguém especializado
psicólogo me ajuda a escolher a gente
chora arrancar os cabelos reza quem sabe
deus vai me mostrar o caminho
ou então amigos dizem dorme dorme que a
resposta vai vir pra ti
a gente espera um sinal porque é tão
difícil escolher sozinho
é difícil arcar com as consequências da
nossa escolha
a gente faz inúmeras atividades para
tentar escolher a gente faz inclusive
lista de prós e contras
a gente coloca na balança quais são os
itens que vão poder levar essa escolha
que vou levar pra outra escolha
o problema de fazer essas lista de prós
e contras é que a gente está tentando
colocar na balança valores e não coisas
que são de fato comparáveis
eu posso ter dez itens de uma lista e 2
na outra mas aqueles dois têm um peso
tão grande que o argumento ele fica
vazio então não adianta tentar
quantificar uma escolha eu posso comprar
um livro desse livro mais pesado é mais
leve e eu tenho o mesmo peso de um outro
livro e isso é fácil agora escolher uma
carreira por exemplo eu posso colocar
vários itens de uma lista e muitos
poucos em outro e isso vai ser
determinante
o problema de escolhas difíceis é que a
gente tenta racionalizar uma escolha que
na verdade ela é emocional ela vem daqui
a gente pode buscar todos os argumentos
fora mas quando os argumentos deveriam
partir da gente a gente tem tanto medo
de arcar com as nossas escolhas que a
gente procura os argumentos de outras
pessoas para embasar as nossas próprias
escolhas
isso fica bastante complicado a gente
fica inseguro
se a gente for pensar a escola nos
prepara muito para fazer a escolha
nem os nossos pais muitas vezes nos
preparam muito para fazer essas escolhas
desde que a gente é muito pequeno as
escolhas são tomadas para gente
os pais acreditam os professores
acreditam que eles têm mais conhecimento
mais experiência de vida ele sabe o que
é melhor
vou te dar o caminho curto e é por aqui
que tu vai só que aí a gente não
desenvolve nas crianças
essa habilidade que é de sentar para
pensar e ouvir a si próprio pensar os
seus próprios argumentos
a gente não faz isso com as crianças
se a gente for pensar na escola a gente
também não faz isso a gente determina
quem são os professores que salas eles
irão estudar qual é a grade curricular
para o período que eles vão ter aula a
gente escolhe um deles então quem são os
professores da turma
a gente escolhe os próprios grupos de
trabalho a gente pode trabalhar com
projetos na escola mas muitos
professores de tênis não antes quais são
os projetos que nós vamos trabalhar com
os alunos
eu conheço pouquíssimas escolas que
escutam os alunos e perguntam que grupos
vocês gostaria de formar aqui dentro
grupos de interesses vocês gostariam de
ter a escola já determina
são esses grupos têm aulas de xadrez tem
o grêmio estudantil escolhe se quer
participar em algo as crianças reclamam
directora da escola e reclama das
escolhas que a escola faz ea escola
continua fazendo as escolhas e não o
vendo as crianças e quando chega no
segundo grau no ensino médio a gente
espera que elas façam consigam tomar
escolha mais difícil da vida delas
escolher o que fazer na carreira ea
gente não entende por que eles sofrem
tanto e não conseguiu se decidir os pais
entram em desespero se lá no 3º ano
filho ainda não sabe o que fazer ficam
desejando a como queria que meu filho
fosse aquele que desde pequenininho
sonhar sim engenheiro oa que imagina que
maravilha essa minha filha desde
pequenininha que quisesse ter sido
médica segue esse caminho vai até o fim
mas essa não é a realidade da maioria
das crianças e essa não foi a minha
realidade eu não tinha idéia do que eu
queria ser eu só dizia que eu não queria
ser professora
eu realmente não sei assim porque eu
tinha essa aversão a profissão não têm
professores na família não ouvia coisas
ruins sobre ser professor
meus pais nunca falavam mal da escola
nem dos professores mas eu sabia que eu
não queria ser professora
eu brinquei muito de escola quando era
criança eu gostava de ser diretora eu
achava o máximo para deixar as crianças
nessa linha usar o poder não gostava
disso
e gostava de ser aluna que ficava lá
vendo a minha amiga preparando aulas pra
dar pra mim mas ser professora de jeito
nenhum eu não queria ser
com 15 anos eu fui para liberato e
decidir fazer química
meu pai era químico em língua porque não
quem sabe o caminho mais fácil mais
seguro tem experiência na família
fui fazer a química
um ano e meio de curso e percebi que não
era pra mim e foi um momento muito
difícil eu sofri bastante e me senti até
mesmo envergonhada de ter tomado uma
decisão errada mas meus pais levaram
numa boa e ceará linense não é isso que
tu quer volta pra escola
voltei pra escola regular e fiquei já
pensando que eu faria no vestibular
pensei em trabalhar com terapia
ocupacional essência fonoaudióloga
pensei então de repente e psicóloga e
passei na unisinos parapsicologia
cheguei aqui eu achei que minha vida
estava resolvida que eu não estava
decidir mais nada
me apavorei havia grade curricular chico
tá porquanto as disciplinas em que
turnos que dias
então ainda teria que fazer muitas
escolhas nesse mesmo tempo fui convidada
para ser professora de inglês no curso
de línguas onde outra onde eu estudei
toda a minha vida
fiquei surpresa com o convite e meus
pais na época não fizer a melhor
pergunta que eles poderiam ter feito nos
perguntar se eu seria feliz aceitando
esse convite não fizeram colocar lista
se vale a pena se não vale a pena
perguntar se eu seria feliz
seguindo esse convite e disse que não
sabia mas que estava disposta a tentar e
comecei a dar aula
comecei a gostar de dar aula e vicky
psicologia então não era pra mim e
troquei para letras mais uma vez meus
pais não disseram aline psicóloga tanto
professor pode ganhar isso não fizeram
uma lista nacional eles me perguntaram
tu acha que vai ser feliz sendo
professora e disse que achava que sim
que estava feliz e foi aí que a seguir
eu decidir terei sido bem mais fácil mas
parecem não vai terminar química não vai
fazer psicologia
eu poderia ser infeliz até hoje culpá
los por isso mas não foi assim que fui
criada eu tinha que tomar a
responsabilidade pelas minhas escolhas
nessa mesma época eu pensei eu preciso
ir atrás de um outro sonho que eu sempre
tinha e eu sonhava em ser atriz
eu queria muito ser 3 a volta que eu
queria muito ser atriz eu queria ser
atriz de hollywood não atriz da globo
recorde nossas coisas em que linhas o
que ele vê la em hollywood eu tinha até
um discurso para aceitar um óscar de
melhor atriz
eu queria muito isso mesmo eu resolvi
então a
cá com essa minha escolha porque a
liberdade não é a habilidade de fazer
aquilo que você quer mas sim a vontade o
desejo de fazer aquilo que você quer e
eu fui fazer um curso
descobri que eu não era tão boa quanto
eu achei que eu era e descobrir também
aos 22 anos que eu não estava disposta a
sacrificar tanto por esse sucesso
hollywoodiano né não era bem isso que eu
queria fazer e isso foi uma lição muito
grande a gente percebe que a gente acha
que quer algo quando na verdade a gente
não está disposto a se sacrificar para
isso é porque a gente não quer tanto
assim
abandonei essa idéia o lidiana terminei
a graduação continuei trabalhando como
professora
trabalhei durante sete anos em uma
escola regular fiz muitas escolhas
escolhas pessoais escolhas profissionais
ao longo dessa minha trajetória
profissional
algumas foram bem simples e outras bem
difíceis e também teve que lidar com
escolhas que foram feitas para mim e não
por mim eu preciso reconhecer que essas
foram as mais difíceis
não sou uma pessoa que aceita muito bem
essas ordens porque tem que ser assim
porque sempre foi assim
eu lido muito mal com conformismo eu
acho que lido mal com conformismo porque
eu lhe dei muito bem com a
responsabilidade da escolha então eu
preciso que a pessoa realmente para mim
o porquê dessa decisão reconhece que
muitas das escolhas que foram feitas
para mim e não por mim foram escolhas
acertadas e que mudaram a trajetória da
minha vida e hoje quando eu olho para
trás eu consigo ver que as pessoas viram
em mim eu não via naquele momento em que
elas percebiam em mim às vezes as
capacidades que nem eu achava que eu
tinha então as escolhas que foram feitas
por mim não eram tão ruins quanto eu
achei para mim não eram tão ruins quanto
eu achei que era mas eu tinha bastante
dificuldade para lidar
hoje eu olho para trás e eu consigo
conectar os pontos eu consigo ver as
escolhas que eu fiz e principalmente eu
consigo ver as escolhas que eu deixei de
fazer as coisas que eu abri mão um lugar
de outra coisa que eu escolhi e eu
conecto esses pontos como steve jobs
disse eu gosto
muito de olhar para trás e conectar meus
pontos descobri conectando meus pontos
que eu sou uma professora que gosta de
colecionar os alunos
eu sou uma professora que prefere trazer
muito mais perguntas para eles do que
respostas e que eu não tenho que saber
tudo e nem posso saber tudo
ser professor não é uma profissão para
quem é conservador ou pelo menos não
deveria de ser que na verdade a nossa
realidade muda a cada semestre
eu não sou a mesma pessoa que eu era um
ano atrás e eu aqui na universidade a
cada semestre tem um grupo diferente de
alunos na escola cada ano a gente tem um
grupo diferente de alunos
a gente pode ensinar a mesma matéria mas
nós não somos os mesmos os alunos não
são os mesmos a realidade não é a mesma
então o que eu quero como professora
ensina os alunos a pensar eu quero
ensinar os alunos a conseguir isto na
responsáveis autores da sua própria vida
que eles consigam tomar suas decisões e
encontrar os seus argumentos para essas
decisões e não há argumentos externos
eu acredito que no momento que a gente
toma as nossas decisões e que a gente
escolhe os nossos próprios argumentos é
que de fato a gente se torna quem a
gente realmente é a gente não precisa
dos argumentos dos outros não deveria de
precisar os argumentos dos outros
eu preciso pensar em mim ali a uft disse
que a gente prefere às vezes não ter que
escolher e pra escolher nós teríamos que
discernir e para discernir nós teríamos
de pensar e parar para pensar parece
complicado demais e triste quando na
verdade deveria de ser interessante
então a gente segue a manada
infantilizados e superficiais
talvez sem maiores angústias mas
certamente sem maiores prazeres
conquistas êxtases e alegrias que
escolhas vocês ainda têm para fazer hoje
quantas dessas escolhas irão mudar o
curso da vida de vocês até o momento que
a gente for morrer
nós estaremos fazendo escolhas ea gente
pode resignar ficar as nossas escolhas a
gente pode mudar o curso da nossa vida
principalmente quando a gente conseguia
olhar para trás
e conectar os pontos eu desejo realmente
que vocês consigam pensar mais e sentir
mais as suas escolhas e eu desejo que
vocês façam ótimas escolhas a partir de
hoje
obrigada